I WOULD ARGUE IT'S NONE OF
THEIR BUSINESS AHEAD OF TIME.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS WITH
THE FIRST LADY.
LAST YEAR PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
MAINSTREAM DESTROYED TRUMP
MEDIA REFERRING TO THE NORTH
KOREAN DICTATOR KIM JONG UN AS
LITTLE ROCKET MAN.
REMEMBER THIS?
>> President Trump: BY THE
WAY, ROCKET MAN SHOULD HAVE
BEEN HANDLED A LONG TIMING A.
A. -- A LONG TIME AGO.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN HANDLED A
LONG TIME AGO BY CLINTON.
I WON'T MENTION THE
REPUBLICANS, RIGHT?
BY OBAMA.
WHY DID THIS, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS A DIFFERENT, THIS IS A
DIFFERENT TIME.
THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN HANDLED
EIGHT YEARS AGO, FOUR YEARS
AGO.
HONESTLY, 15 YEARS AGO.
AND 20 YEARS AGO.
AND 25 YEARS AGO.
THIS SHOULDN'T BE HANDLED NOW.
BUT I'M GOING TO HANDLE IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HANDLE IT.
>> Sean: REMEMBER AT THE
TIME PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
CRITICIZEDDED THE PRESIDENT'S
TOUGH RHETORIC BUT IT HAS
CLEARLY WORKED NOW THE SUMMIT
IS SET FOR NEXT MONTH.
IN AN INTERVIEW ON "FACE THE
NATION" THE NEW SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO WAS ASKED TO
DESCRIBE WHAT TRUCK HIM ABOUT
THE NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR --
STRUCK HIM ABOUT THE NORTH
KOREAN DICTATOR.
>> HE IS VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE IN
THE SENSE HE KNOWS THE FILES.
HE IS VERY CAPABLE OF ENGAGING
IN COMPLEX SET OF DISCUSSIONS.
WHEN I ASK HIM A QUESTION
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT IS A
LITTLE OFF, HE ANSWERS IT.
THERE ARE NO CARDS.
IT'S CHAIRMAN KIM IN THIS CASE
INTERACTING WITH ME DIRECTLY.
HAVING A ROBUST DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT THE OUTLINES OF A
SUCCESS NEGOTIATION BETWEEN
OUR TWO COUNTRIES MIGHT
ULTIMATELY BE.
>> Sean: WITH THE REACTION,
FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST SEBASTIAN GORKA AND
AUTHOR OF THE BEST SELLER.
A FRIEND, WE DON'T ALWAYS
AGREE.
BUT HE IS MY BROTHER.
GERALDO RIVERA.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
BOTH OF YOU.
LET ME START WITH YOU,
GERALDO.
I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A FAN.
POMPEO IS A GENIUS.
I HAVE BEEN A FAN OF HIS FOR A
LONG TIME AND I'M GLAD HE IS
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE.
WHAT HE SAYS TO ME IS
IMPRESSIVE.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
TRUMP CALLS HIM "LITTLE ROCKET
MAN" AND HE SHOWS MILITARY
FORCE AND PUTS SANCTIONS IN
PLACE.
THE ROCKETS STOP BEING FIRED.
WORLD IS SAFER.
THREE HOSTAGES ARE RELEASED.
HE CROSSES THE D.M.Z. AND WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
YOUR KNOW -- YOU KNOW WHAT?
GOOD STORY.
>> I'LL SAY.
IF YOU CONSIDER HOW MUCH WE
TRAVELED SINCE THE OLYMPICS.
JUST SINCE THE OLYMPICS.
IF I WAS A DIPLOMAT I'D SAY I
WAS CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC.
I'M NOT A DIPLOMAT.
AND I'M NOT DIPLOMATIC.
>> Sean: NO KIDDING.
WE KNOW YOU.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT.
I FEEL WE HAVE MOVED SO FAR.
AND POMPEO IS A NUTS AND BOLTS
KIND OF GUY.
IT'S NOT PIE IN THE SKY.
IT'S NOT WISHFUL THINKING ON
THE PART OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THESE ARE MEANINGFUL STEPS.
RELEASE OF THE HOSTAGES.
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT IN TWO WEEKS
HE WILL BE BLOWING UP THE
TUNNELS TO HIS TESTING
FACILITIES.
THE FACT THAT HE IS AGREEING
TO DISMANTLE.
SHIP COMPONENT PARTS TO OAK
RIDGE, TENNESSEE.
IT IS SPECTACULAR, SEAN.
IF THIS INDEED WHAT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN, THIS IS THE BIGGEST
MOVE TOWARD PEACE SINCE THE
FOUNDING OF THE UNITED
NATIONS.
>> Sean: AND THAT LITERALLY
THE ALLIANCE CREATED BY THE
PRESIDENT, ISRAEL, THE
JORDANIANS, THE EGYPTIANS,
SAUDIS, EMIRATES.
NO CARGO PLANES OF CACHE.
HUGE DIFFERENCE.
>> IT'S AMAZING WHAT
DIFFERENCE ONE ELECTION CAN
MAKE.
IT TRULY IS.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF RESULTS
YOU WOULD BE PROUD OF AT THE
ENT OF A TWO-TERM PRESIDENCY.
I WAS IN TOUCH WITH MIKE
POMPEO TODAY.
THE SPIRITS ARE VERY HIGH.
WE HAVE TO BE CAUTIOUS.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A
DICTATORSHIP.
THIS IS A REGIME THAT KEPT ITS
PEOPLE PRISONER.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU PUT
THESE THINGS ON A WHITE BOARD
IN JUST 15 MONTHS.
ALL OF THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN
ACHIEVED.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN REMARKABLE
TO HAVE A SUMMIT ON KOREAN
PEACE IN EIGHT YEARS' TIME.
NOT NEXT WEEK OR THE WEEK
AFTER.
SO STUNNING.
FROM THE 70th BIRTHDAY OF
THE MODERN ISRAELI STATE TO
THE OPENING OF THE EMBASSY,
THE HIT JUST KEEP COMING.
>> Sean: GERALDO, I WILL SAY
THIS.
THAT AND PULLING OUT OF THE
IRANIAN DEAL AND THE GREAT
NEWS ON THE ECONOMY, AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
ALL THE NOISE I ARGUE IS NOT
GOING TO MEAN A THING WHEN IT
COMES TO 2018 ELECTION.
I BELIEVE THIS ELECTION WILL
BE ABOUT THE ECONOMY DOING SO
MUCH BETTER.
A WORLD BEING A SAFER PLACE.
A PRESIDENT KEEPING HIS
PROMISES AND A DESIRE TO ROLL
BACK TAX CUTS AND IMPEACH THIS
PRESIDENT WILL BE ON THE
BALLOT IN EVERY CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT.
>> YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING
THAT YOU SAY THAT.
I AGREE.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHO ELSE
AGREES?
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" WEEK IN
REVIEW HAD AN ARTICLE I
THOUGHT WAS VERY, VERY
TELLING.
IT SAID LIBERALS ARE SO SMUG,
THEY KNOW IT ALL.
THEY ARE SO SURE THAT THEY
HAVE GOD ON THEIR SIDE AND
THAT TRUMP IS THE DEVIL
INCARNATE THAT THEIR ATTITUDE
IS GOING TO LEAD THEM DOWN THE
PRIM ROSE PATH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING A
SPECTACULAR JOB WITH THE
ECONOMY AS YOU MENTIONED.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT,
HISPANIC UNEMPLOYMENT AND
FEMALE UNEMPLOYMENT,
INDICATORS OF OPTIMISM AND
EVERYTHING POINTED UP.
IF HE CAN DELIVER TRUE
DENUCLEARIZED KOREAN
PENINSULA, THE ATOMIC CLOCK
THAT TICKS TOWARD MIDNIGHT
WOULD L HAVE TO BE SET BACK
FIVE OR TEN MINUTES.
THIS IS A PROFOUND STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
>> Sean: GIVE DR. GORKA THE
LAST WORD.
>> SEAN, GERALDO, THE
PRESIDENT MAKES PROMISES.
HE KEEPS PROMISES.
THIS IS WHAT MAKING AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN LOOKS LIKE.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE SEVEN
MORE YEARS OF IT AND THEN
EIGHT YEARS OF PRESIDENT
PENCE.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT
PRESIDENT GERALDO?
I THOUGHT HE WAS RUNNING.
>> PRESIDENT HANNITY, I HEAR
HE IS NEXT IN LINE.
>> Sean: EVERYONE WRITES
THESE STORIES ABOUT ME, NOBODY